as we told you earlier in the show
President Trump is not backing down from
his claims calling Baltimore a rat and
rodent infested mess
he's also criticizing Baltimore
congressman Elijah Cummings joining us
now is Michael Noel's host of the
Michael Noel's show on The Daily The
Daily wire what did you think of the
president's comments and what do you
make of accusations that it's racist
well I mean I know that we've boiled
this word down or diluted this word
racism to mean just about anything we
disagree with these days but in a very
technical way the comments are not
racist
they do not bring up anybody's race they
don't discriminate against someone for
their race Bernie Sanders made almost
exactly the same comments nobody called
him a racist for it the black Democratic
mayor of Baltimore made for tougher
comments on Baltimore using similar
language to President Trump nobody
called her racist they only say that
this is racist because the president
said it and this is the line that they
use when they've run out of an argument
now the question it seems to me the
comments are true Baltimore has some of
the worst crime in the entire country
they've some of the highest murder rates
in the entire country it's a really
tough place to live
the mayor herself said there are rats
and trash everywhere and that is a
failure of the political leadership
including Elijah Cummings who has been
the representative there for a long time
he has been in office in Baltimore for
36 years the problem has only gotten
worse the New York Times admitted this
just this past March they called it a
tragedy of what has happened there so
the comments are true the comments are
not racist the question is or the
comments politically helpful to the
president or they politically harmful to
the president and it seems to me there
they're quite helpful as you have right
now presidential candidates Elizabeth
Warren Kamala Harris and others
defending al Sharpton al Sharpton who is
now going to have a press conference in
Baltimore a race hustling extortionist
he launched his career on a rape hoax
and I'm calling for violence against
Jews in New York and a number of other
egregious actions in his life you now
have the Democratic Party endorsing this
man who even in his own city of New York
is extraordinarily unpopular it seems to
me this is a bad idea for Democrats who
want to win a presidential election next
year they are endorsing very unpopular
people
they're associating themselves with
unpopular people they're coming out and
hanging the police for instance the
third most popular institution in the
country third most trusted they're even
protesting the American flag they're
even celebrating people who denigrate
the American flag this seems to be
President Trump's political superpower
he's able to get his opponents to defend
the most unpopular institutions and to
identify him even with say the American
flag itself or safety or security or
prosperity I don't I don't know what's
gonna happen in the debates tomorrow
night we have the the Democrats we have
Joe Bernie Sanders on stage tomorrow and
and you had quoted him as well as Mark
Irons has quoted him earlier in the
newscast is the fact that here's the
quote right here from the Burlington
Free Press and he says you know when
you're visiting Baltimore you know you
would think this was a we're in a third
world country so that's on the record
there from Bernie Sanders we'll see if
he's asked about that tomorrow in the
debates but I do want to get to
Archbishop William Lauri the Archbishop
of Baltimore you yourself are Catholic
William Lauri Archbishop said you know
the people there's good people in
Baltimore they deserve the support of
elected officials you know doesn't the
president have the responsibility to
promote civic discourse and in a really
shy away from personal attacks of course
well president Trump is not making a
personal attack against Elijah Cummings
he's making a professional attack the
man has had 36 years to clean up his own
district and it's only gotten worse
under his leadership so I think the the
attack against representative Cummings
is absolutely appropriate and of course
the the people of Baltimore which is
historically a wonderful city and has
fallen into very difficult times or they
deserve decent political leadership and
that has been deprived of them for the
past several decades but that's not
president Trump's fault president Trump
didn't cause the problems in Baltimore
and if he's shining a light on it now
then I hope that the people who are
actually responsible for that city will
respond but instead I think they want to
launch unfair attacks and malign the
character of the president rather than
actually clean up their own towns but
your colleague Ben Shapiro actually says
the president does not have a plan to
help Baltimore what do you make of that
well I'm a federalist as has been and as
are many other people so of course I
don't think the president has any
antipathy to where the people of
Baltimore I think
wants to help the people of Baltimore
but what at the federal level is the
President of the United States supposed
to do for a city that suffers from local
political corruption I'm very skeptical
of federal plans as Ronald Reagan used
to say the nine most dangerous words in
the English language or I'm from the
government and I'm here to help this
this is incumbent on people at the local
level and at the state level to do
something about it and I don't think we
need an answer for every single
political problem in the country from
the leader of the free world you had
suggested that that this might help the
president how is this gonna help the
president I mean this just seems to be
nasty politics people trading barbs on
on Twitter unfortunately though negative
politics works and unfortunately attack
ads work as well that's why all
politicians use them it would be
wonderful if the president were able to
make himself acceptable to a wide slew
of Americans and very kind and genial
and and operating in ways of individual
grace that we ourselves want to operate
in our political moment isn't terribly
graceful or charitable or merciful and
if he has attacks being lobbed against
him from Elijah Cummings and from all of
his other political opponents unfair
attacks maligning him he has to fight
back you know you have two different
tactical and strategic approaches you
have the kind genial Republicans Mitt
Romney say who want to stay away from
cultural issues and you have the culture
warriors who are not going to win so
much by making themselves acceptable but
by portraying their opponents as
unacceptable Governor Romney lost his
election for president President Trump
won his election and we'll see in 2020
if that strategy is going to to bear
fruit and in moving forward hey Michael
Knowles thank you so much from The Daily
wire appreciate your time perhaps
thank you very much